President Biden's border Securities are
being warned to step down or be fired
after a tumultuous first year on the job
but in a letter commissioner Chris
Magnus is not complying he says quote I
want to make this clear I have no plans
to resign as CBP commissioner I didn't
take this job as a Resume Builder I came
to Washington D.C moved my family here
because I care about this agency its
Mission and the goals of this
Administration Fox News contributor and
retired acting ice director Tom Homan
joins us now uh Tom we've been talking
about this all morning long uh Ken
cuccinelli pointed out and a piece of
sound we played didn't Chris Magnus
reflect all the policies of the bite
Administration so why they want him to
go help us make sense of this
well you can make signs of it because
you know if secretary secretary mayork
has been telling the truth the border
security has operation control the
border the YC foreign Magnus you should
be giving them some sort of reward but
we know we know secretary says lied I
know it's this morning in Fox news.com
to talk about the story and in that
story there's a clip of me and Griff
Jenkins talking a year and a half ago
right after Magnus got nominated and I
said then a worse decision I could ever
make the man is a bad choice because
he'd be oversaid because I'm a reason
one of your Tucson chief of police he
refuses officers ordered his officers
not to assist ice or CBP he supported
Sanctuary City policies he he talked bad
about the Trump policies and secure the
Border even when it came to Public
Safety address in Tucson he refused to
work with men when the books on ice and
that's who they expect to run CBP look
he needs to go they need to fire him but
they need to fire my Orchestra because
she's simply doing my office told him to
do yeah I mean the job of secretary
mayorkas is to protect our country
National Security and yet we see 98
apprehended known terrorists just this
year he has been Reckless with our
national security
you know I used analogy last night you
want to fire the waitress who delivered
a bad meal to your table meanwhile the
person who cooked the meal the cook he's
off scot-free yes yeah it's a great
analogy this is another example of
mallorca's bail leadership he's a coward
because he thinks Republicans are going
to take back Congress there's going to
be investigations on the border and he
and and Madness is going to throw away
he's going to put on magnets but look
secretary Marcus I'll say it again he's
being peached because Magnus is doing
exactly what he wants him do uh
secretary mayorkus is the architect of
the Border failure historic border
failure our country's less State farmers
leadership he needs to go to
there it is I think that's the best
explanation I've heard this call this
guy is going to be hauled in front of
Congress and they don't want him
answering questions because he's
completely incompetent
um do you expect action from let's say
House Republicans do date the majority
do you think they have the guts to to
impeach my orcas
they better I'll call them out too I
mean bottom line is this this is an
immigration crisis anymore just not an
immigration crisis as as Rachel just
said this is a national security crisis
we got over one million recorded
gotaways they've arrested since Joe
Biden became president 114 known as
suspected Terrors who tried to come
across this enter this country illegally
so how many the one man our
non-suspected chairs that came here to
do us harm we don't know but someday
we're going to find out it's gonna be a
bad day for this country secretary
mayorkas has made this country less safe
since day one he became secretary yeah
there is no question about it and firing
this guy is not going to change the
policies or the situation for the people
who are living along that border Tom
Holman uh I I can't wait for you to hold
the Republican Congress at least the
house if they now that we know they have
the majority accountable for impeaching
secretary mayorkas because he is
definitely derelict of his duty Tom
Holman thank you thank you Tom I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis